Jerry don't worry dear
I'll be alright what about the kid who's
worth over there okay honey
Sally's taking care of them you should
be with them dear they're so young then
now imagine our thoughts
why don't you go home for dinner they'll
take good care of me here
Carol's right Jerry the tiller needs
some reassurance now we are nurse on
duty in this room around the clock
myself or another doctor within the call
you better go home all right but I'll be
back first thing in the morning
but I love you honey
I
dr. Simmons what is this with Carol how
bad is she
you've known us for years I want you to
give it to me straight what's what's
happening to it I'll be frank with you
Jerry
she has tetanus a highly dangerous
disease she's going to be a very sick
girl right now I can't honestly tell you
how sick but be prepared for this she's
going to have a rough time at the very
best she'll be in the hospital for weeks
and weeks now you take good care of the
youngsters and we'll let you know if
there's any change here thank you doctor
I'll be back in the morning I know
you'll do everything I mean of course we
will Jerry everything pump what I can't
figure doctor why Carol wasn't immunized
for this thing Jerry I don't know how
many times I've urged her to be mu not
hit she always put it off no time this
week that sort of thing and now now is
the payoff
see you tomorrow doctor
you see the hospitals the best place mom
will have everything she needs their
special nurses and all will make out
until she feels better the dad mama feel
real sick because she never gives them
yes Mike she is sick and you're right
she has courage that's why I know she'll
be home again in a few weeks until then
we'll just have to run the house well do
all we can to help that won't we Jenny
sure dad out of the dishes every night
you'll see I know you will
well give me a kiss and get to bed
tomorrow's a school day yeah dad mom
will come home won't she she has two son
she just has to will say I prayers for
tonight dad she'll be all right
if she'd just gotten her shots but I
think back on how it happened it just
doesn't seem possible
how could a little scratch like that
caused so much trouble she didn't even
say anything about it that day
everything went along the same as usual
Jerry how the hamburgers coming the kids
will be here any minute
coming up onion relish chili sauce it
works I estimated six for Mike do you
think that'll hold it oh here come the
troops now hey you should have seen the
scrimmage
I completed four passes the last one was
about 50 yards well 30 anyway no that's
great camp I'm sorry I got home too late
to be there sit out dinner's ready
hey mom could you wash my uniform so
it'll be clean for the game tomorrow
sure my do it I don't know what we do
without her she holds the whole family
together we never think about something
you have until you don't have it anymore
how long was it before she started
feeling fact
it all happened so fast Jerry hi what
are you doing prick well I'm not feeling
so good that's why I call Oh what's
wrong
oh I feel kind of feverish and have this
stiffness not my muscles and then well
I'm weak all over and and I have a
splitting headache another thing I don't
know exactly how to explain it but well
I'm so Restless or something maybe you
ought to give the doctor a call it's
probably nothing serious but well I'd
feel better anyway okay let me know he's
gonna find out coming wait okay I'll
come let you know bye sweetie
Gerald you know I'm not disposed to be
an alarmist quite the contrary
but after what you told me on the phone
I felt it my duty to or you down here on
the double some things you can't let go
now try and remember just when it was
that you got this scratch and the how
let's see it must have been yes
Tuesday's in the middle of the morning I
was gardening and something in the mush
I don't know what it was make my finger
a little and that's all in the mulch so
your hands were dirty
well you can't garden and keep
snow-white hands you know yes I know my
wife has a green thumb too Carol you
never got those tetanus immunizations we
talked about did you know I I just never
did get around to it do you suppose that
might be what's wrong well I don't say
that it is but it could very well be
we're going to admit you to the hospital
observation and further testing right
now
what a shock it was when the doctor told
me tetanus lockjaw something you never
even think about hello oh yeah that's
Allie thanks so much for staying with
the kids today I don't know yet but I'm
going over first thing in the morning
now I surely will and thanks for calling
bye good morning is dr. Simmons in dr.
Simmons sleeping with your wife no mr.
winning well why didn't you step down
the hall and wait for him thank you oh
here he comes now
morning dr. Haas Carol this morning
Maude is expected Gary I told you is
gonna be a long tough fight he's going
to get worse before she gets better we
have to face that we've had one good
break though she shall no adverse
reaction to tetanus out of toxins so
we've been able to give her large doses
of that it should help
tonight's here well yes Jerry yes it's
not pretty and be very quiet any little
noise or vibration it could cause us
faster oh won't she know who I am
oh yes she's a conscious sedated but
she'll know you
dr. katz would do anything Jerry we're
doing everything we can
she's trying to get your attention look
lockjaw why does she have to suffer well
you have every right to be upset Jerry
but this can happen anybody who isn't
protected and the suffering goes with it
let's find a seat I'll give you some
background so you live a better picture
of what's going on
Jerry tetanus bacteria grow in the
intestines of grass eating animals such
as horses their cow so as you may guess
they're frequently found around barnyard
and fields used for grazing but this
doesn't mean they're just way out in the
country far from city life their dairy
is in and around every city in the
United States that means cows their
writings table park areas whose many
different activities involving
grass-eating animals wherever you are
further and this is even more
significant when the bacteria in the
soil dry up tiny spores or form each one
is deadly as the bacteria and they live
almost indefinitely these spores can go
anywhere carried by the wind and lie and
wait for a victim and not just outdoors
they're brought into home churches
schools everywhere on shoes clothing
it's safe to say that tetanus spores may
be found in any room you later
of course the spores may be concentrated
wherever manure is used to fertilize
trees and shrubs and flowers that's
probably the source of Carol's infection
we fear the spores or bacteria most in
dirty wounds such as punctures and nails
gunshot wounds mortar mobile accident
but they can enter the body through any
break in the skin no matter how
superficial over fifty percent of all
cases come from wounds so trivial that
people don't even seek medical attention
and usually involve the abrasion which
is contaminated with soil such as the
scratch on Carol's finger although
everybody is exposed to tetanus because
everybody gets a scratch occasionally
certain types of occupations are more
frequently exposed for example
construction workers field hands outdoor
laborer
industrial workers and plants and
factories who worked with their hand and
then there are children you know how
active they are always falling down
scraping in new year a hand
recently women have become more and more
exposed to you see more than ever
they're participating in sports going
camping working in garden they need
protection just as much as men do once
inside the body the germs produced a
powerful nerve toxin or poison that
causes painful convulsions or spasms of
the voluntary muscle one of the most
frequently affected muscles is the jaw
causing the patient's jaw to close
tightly this characteristic symptom gave
rise to the common or slang name for
tetanus lockjaw over half the infected
people die from the disease unless
treated quickly I hope we've caught
Carroll sometime
the terrible thing about tetanus is that
it's absolutely unnecessary it should
never happen yet we have hundreds of
cases each year in this country remember
when you were in the service and you got
your tetanus immunization well tetanus
vaccine is for all practical purposes
100% effective and there's virtually no
serious reactions of course you should
have booster immunization at regular
intervals there are no documented cases
of immunized person dying from tests
most men get their immunization in the
service so a big problem is with women
they should be immunized too for the
past 30 years or so immunizations have
been given to infants in combination
with diphtheria and whooping cough don't
worry Mike and Jenny have had theirs but
there are millions of children under
five who've never had this protection
they need immunization another thing
tetanus is no respecter of age either
it's strikes anytime from birth to old
age there are millions of elderly people
in the United States who have never been
immunized and should be there'd be no
tetanus in the United States at all if
everyone would get their immunizations
but that's water over the dam for Carol
if she pulls through this time we'll
make sure she's every night I mean she
could get it again
oh yes having this disease does not
confer immunity you must have the toxoid
you just said over half of the people
who died
what a gerald chance that's the truth
Jerry Carroll has a 50-50 chance maybe a
little better her symptoms have
progressed rather slowly that's on the
good side let's just say she's holding
her own right now so if there's no
change tonight there's no use of you
sitting around here much better you'll
be home with the kids if you are needed
I'll call you
what would I do without her
what would the children do she just
can't can't
yes what do you want honey
well mom always reads mice very much to
me before test could you do it for me
Dad
why certainly let me see the book you
ready necessary in ECE SSA ri-right
habitation h ABI P and P R oh and hello
yes
yes of course I'll be there right away
Mike I've got to go to the hospital for
a little while you go next door and tell
mrs. barns will you she'll come over and
stay with you and I'll see you in the
morning
what's the matter dad I just I just want
to talk to Lisa you mind mrs. Barnes
okay you got here in a hurry Jerry sit
down for a moment
quick no I'm all right well what's wrong
is she worth well she's had learned GU
fast that means closing off her windpipe
which could stop her breathing we've had
to insert a tube in her windpipe one of
the hazards of tetanus what are her
chances now well the odds have certainly
gotten worse it's not hopeless but it's
not a good situation if we can pull it
through tonight I'd say she has a good
chance then can I hear if you make it
brief he's heavily sedated she may not
know you this time
she'll get through the night she will
make it all right things will be like
they always were
she's not going to make it there's no
sense in killing myself she's she's not
gonna make
here you come out of it what what's the
matter
you're exhausted that's what's the
matter three days and no sleep finally
caught up with you this morning morning
how's Carol good news her condition
improved during the night he's gonna
pull through we feel sure why don't you
go call the kids they're scared too and
then come on back here
okay I'll come
hello hi there she is
sure sure
my mom's gonna be all right
daddy said so she come home well what
did the kids think about the good news I
talked to Mike he was really pleased
good good
can I see Kerala would it be best if
you've been weightless afternoon to sere
Jerry she's still a mighty sick girl and
will be for several days she would stay
here in the hospital for quite a while
those stiff rigid muscles and spasms
will persist but they will gradually get
fewer and further apart until she's
completely recovered I can tell you this
we were lucky
mighty left tetanus is something doctors
dread
I told you before even with prompt
round-the-clock treatment we still lose
about 50% of the cases and without
treatment death is virtually certain if
people only realize this sort of thing
wouldn't happen right no I won't keep
you anymore maybe I ought to get some
breakfast to me he's a good idea I'm
going back to Carol I'll I'll see you
this afternoon
so unnecessary there wouldn't be a case
of tetanus in this country ever if
people would just get em you know
you